Every child, including you, has two parents. A mom
and a dad, and each parent passes down one
copy of their chromosomes. Here, I've color-coded them for
you, to make it easier to see. Your blue chromosomes
came from dad, and your pink chromosomes came from
mom. In the same way that your parents gave their
chromosomes, one day, you're going to pass down your chromosomes
to a child of your own. But the question is,
what will they look like? Now, because of meiosis, which
we learned about in Lesson five, recombination causes a parent's
chromosome pair to mix and match their information roughly equally.
So when you have kids, your chromosomes in your germ
cells, when they undergo meiosis are actually going to exchange pieces
of information, so that no longer do you have these
discrete individual chromosomes, the set you got from mom and
the set you got from dad, but you're going to mix and
match the information you got from mom and dad
on the chromosomes. So the chromosomes that you pass down
to your child will actually be a mix and
match of your own parents' chromosomes that they gave to
you. But every time recombination happens during meiosis for
each of your germ cells, every time a new sex
cell or gamete is made, a different recombination happens. And
the set of chromosomes that you pass down to one
child will actually be a different mix and
match of your own parents' chromosomes, then another
child you pass down those chromosomes to. There
are virtually an infinite number of combinations for this
to happen. So, even though each of these
children is receiving half of their chromosomes from
you, the parent, the half that you give
one child is roughly only about half the same
as the set you give to the other child. For any given parent, you and a
full sibling only share about 50% of the
same genetic information. Since it's the same for
both parents, together you're considered about 50% related
to each other, through both parents, because it's
about the same through individual parents. And it
all has to do with recombination. So over all,
we can look at identity by state.
So, understanding the effects of recombination and
the fact that a 50% relation between siblings, is not the same thing as
a 50% relation between parent and child. What would you assume if you found
a 100% relatedness with someone? Take a look at the answers and select one.